- [Male] You keep saying how excited
you are about this
depression.
- (laughs) Yes, yes.
- The depression that's coming out.
And you're half joking, half not, but
really--
- No, I'm a hundred
percent fucking serious.
(laughter)
- Okay.
- [Gary] There's no joking.
I've eaten shit for the last nine years
to put me in a position to capitalize.
Guys, nine years ago when
I started VayerNedia.
(edgy music)
(yelling)
You got your perspective.
(cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
Yo!
First of all, I just
wanna thank all of you
for being today one more time.
How did it go?
(cheering)
Great.
Really what I wanna do is just set up
a little bit of a framework, of a recap
of everything I've sensed
over the last two days.
There are mic stands in
four places throughout.
For everybody up there in the bleachers,
there's right there, so
I really wanna go into Q&A and
maximize our time together.
But I what I really
wanna talk about before
I go into that is, in the macro
I genuinely believe that
this is the greatest era
to be navigating in the human race.
I just actually believe that.
I believe that we've
made so many advances,
but most of all, everybody
that's here today
has the luxury of being alive during
the prime years of the internet,
which is the disproportionate
invention in the human race.
The internet was awesome in 1996,
but it wasn't at the
scale that it is today.
And the opportunities are ludicrous.
For all the disruption that's happening
in all four of these categories that
so many of you are in,
with all the innovations
of the companies that have the leverage,
with referral fees and
things of that nature,
you too could take the
power of that platform
and you could have the relationship with
the end consumer if you chose to.
And that's just not how it used to be.
It used to be too expensive to do that.
It was expensive to build 50 offices.
It was expensive to give Walmart millions
of dollars to put your
product on the shelf.
This is the moment, this
is really the moment.
And a lot of my passion
and the reason I've
gotten so loud, especially over the last
two or three or four years, is predicated
that I just know this is the moment.
I know when you have the best hand,
you need to go all in.
And the fact that you
are even at this event,
know about me and or this
space or this movement,
is a fundamental advantage.
There are millions and millions, and tens
of millions of agents
and dealers and companies
and people that look like you for a living
that haven't even begun the process
of accepting the realities
of the technology
advances in our society.
So it would make me super fucking happy
if everybody clapped it up for each other.
(clapping)
Let's do that again because
that was some tennis shit.
(laughter)
(cheering)
The content is the variable of success.
We have an incredible team and I've heard
unbelievable accolades
of the presentations
around media and things of that nature.
We, other people for free, you know,
you can figure out how to
get in front of people.
Pre-roll YouTube ads for what you do
for a living is something you can
look up with a Google search and
pretty much get on your way, right?
It's the creative that
you put in front of people
that is contextual to the mindset,
the culture, the target.
If anything I hope that everybody leaves
this year, so many people
came back this year
from last year, talked about they started
their podcast, they went more.
Just an enormous amount of success
and beginnings of success throughout
this entire day for me, but
there's a part of me that really wants
to put pressure before we go into Q&A.
And I'd like you guys to start lining up
if you got questions,
let's start doing that
because I wanna get into it.
There's an enormous amount of passion
I have for people to get excited about
producing a lot more content.
And when I mean a lot
more, there's something
I got to say to a couple
breakout sessions,
one of the reasons I had my team
do a fake takeover of my Twitter account
the other day was I wanted to find
a creative way to figure out if I could
post a hundred tweets a day.
A hundred.
And to be very honest with you,
that was just a precursor to me
to figure out if I could do 500 or 1,000.
The sheer volume of content that I think
will be the differentiator of the mature
understanding of this
social and digital web,
is gonna be the differentiator.
You're not gonna be
able to continue to just
beat your competitors by
knowing to run Facebook ads.
People will catch up over
the next two or three years.
So I'm already starting
with the thesis that's
gonna help you compete
which is your ability to somehow figure
out how to make 500 or 1,000 pieces
a month instead of three.
There's a lot of you on your first try
on Facebook ads with one
piece of content converted.
It's that underpriced.
It's that remarkable,
that you are able to win
when you didn't know what
the fuck you were doing.
So
this is a really important time,
and I'd love to get into some very
specific questions so let's do it, so.
Go ahead, my friend.
- [Male] I'm a little nervous here.
- [Gary] Don't worry.
- [Male] Cool.
First of all, as Miamian,
I think it's really
cool that you're here,
and welcome to the city.
I think you're a guy that understands
the relevance of hubs that affect culture,
and Miami really is
affecting the Latin-American,
North American
nexus of culture.
- I agree.
- [Male] Which is a big
growing thing.
- I agree.
- [Male] And I think it's
awesome that you're in on that.
My question is man, you're winning in one
of the loudest spaces that's the most
wide open tournament for
a anybody to compete in.
And I think one of your
big differentiators
when I listen to you that I really like
is that your end goal is to
build an empire of honey.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Male] You're a context guy, right?
Who's the closest who's come to building
an empire of honey, and
what are the obstacles that
are gonna come out of that?
It sounds like such common sense.
What do you foresee as an
obstacle in accomplishing that?
- [Gary] So I think there's probably tons
of big businesses that
are run by nice people,
like Warren Buffett sounds nice.
I mean I'm sure there's plenty.
The truth to your question
is I have no idea.
The amount of time I've ever spent
looking at other people, that's not.
And by the way, I think it's a good thing
for people that learn that way.
I love when people go to another company,
spend a week, we do 4Ds for that reason.
There's a lot of people
that learn that way,
but there's a reason that I got Ds and Fs.
I have a different style of learning,
and it's not gonna be
looking at oh, Nestle
did that, or early days
of Johnson and Johnson.
That's not how I roll.
The consequences that come along with
running a business or what makes it hard,
is when you create a nice culture,
entitlement takes over.
It's hard to motivate when you're feeding
everybody and taking on all the stress.
So there's always
ramifications to a style,
but at the end of the day, for all of you
that are looking to build something,
if you're not happy and it's your thing,
you need to reset.
Somebody told me yesterday in 4Ds
that they fired every
one of their employees.
Which I thought was fucking amazing
and super self aware.
Like, you know, the end.
I think that there's a
lot of ways to do this,
but I just don't understand how to do it
in a way that wouldn't make you happy.
I hate conflict and negativity,
so why would I build a company where
that is rampant, there's
no amount of money
that can close the gap
on that feeling for me.
The end.
That's it.
- Thanks for everything.
- [Gary] You got it, brother.
- [Female] How do you prioritize creating
content and creating
videos and social stuff when a lot
of the time is taken up
by clients.
- Makes sense.
- [Female] And inspections
and things like that.
- [Gary] First thing's first
which is, what's your ambition?
For a lot of people here,
they don't have to, right?
To me it comes down to,
how many hours do you work
and what are you doing within those hours
and how much money do you wanna take home?
If you're doing really
well and you want content,
you could hire somebody to film you
and post-produce, you could right?
If your ambition is enormous,
you could work an extra hour.
You know, so this is just about resources
of money and time, mapped
against your ambition.
There's no I can't.
Of course you can.
Every single person here wastes an hour
every day on dumb shit including myself.
- [Female] Including myself.
- [Gary] Of course, so
stop doing dumb shit.
(laughter)
Right?
- You're right.
- [Gary] But it starts
with the self awareness
that that's the case, and then it depends
on how ambitious you are.
If you're buying into my model,
you're running a marathon.
I'm talking about branding and long-term
wealth creation, I'm not talking about
short-term sales arbitrage.
- [Female] Right, right.
- [Gary] So people pick short-term.
They wanna buy a Lambo.
They wanna go on a better
vacation this year.
That's why they don't do it.
Which ultimately, in this industry
and the four here, will lead to the
demise because the only thing left
is gonna be your personal brand.
- [Female] I shoulda know
that was gonna be your answer.
I just figured maybe, I don't know.
- [Gary] Sometimes you have to
hear it.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] There's so many things that--
- [Female] That's such a
typical answer across the board.
- [Gary] 'Cause it's the answer.
(laughter)
- I know.
I don't know why I didn't think of it.
- [Gary] Like my favorite
thing on my social
is when somebody on Instagram posts,
'cause I read 'em right, and they're like,
"hey Gary V, you know what?
"Unsubscribe, I'm done with you.
"You say the same shit over and over."
I'm like would you like me to make up
shit I don't believe in?
Just to mix it up?
It's very true, but the question is,
what less people talk about is ambition.
You know, when I talk
about work-life balance,
I talk about happiness and ambition.
There is no right work-life balance.
Like what?
Everyone's living a different life.
Like if you love what
you do, it's your hobby?
Like when I was seven or eight or nine
or 10, when it snowed I wanted to shovel
people's yards, not build a snowman.
It's in my DNA, it's what I like.
So when you love it, the hell are you
supposed to do, not do it?
But you have to know what you're up to.
My biggest problem is people
mouths don't map their actions.
They're gonna build a
huge fucking brokerage,
but they can't find that hour because
they have the watch The
English Premier League.
- [Female] Thanks Gary.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Female] Hi, Gary.
Oh man, that's very loud.
Hello, I'm Ashley Skain from Atlanta.
So I'm an extrovert and
I have to talk it out
to make sure that I'm comprehending
what the hell you're saying.
- Let's go, I'm ready.
- And that it makes sense.
Okay, cool.
So the chick earlier there, she was
talking about, "oh contracts, inspections,
"yadda, yadda, yadda,"
at the end of the day.
And I know you're like,
"content, content, content."
I love it.
And you're like maximize
every minute of the day,
still have that balance.
At the end of it though, it's like for me,
I'm starting off fully in real estate,
and I have a partner who is also my real
estate partner, but we have a roofing and
construction company where
it ties hand-in-hand.
- [Gary] Understood.
- [Female] So he's doing that,
I'm really full time real estate.
At the end of it, I'm just starting off,
and I wanna do that
content, content, content,
and I don't necessary
have the cash to leverage
all the shmegma, I know that's
kinda gross, but I don't know.
You know, like the contracts and stuff,
but when you build you brand, it has to
be about you so how do I leverage without
maybe having the pockets
deep enough to leverage
properly for all that other stuff?
- [Gary] By patience.
- [Female] Oh man.
I knew it was gonna be
a freaking easy answer.
- [Gary] Let me tell you something--
- [Female] I'm an instant gratification,
so maybe that's my
problem right?
- You're gonna be
instantly in trouble.
- [Female] Yeah, that's a problem.
- [Gary] Yeah, so like look, let me just
tell everybody what happened.
I like to remind people about my career.
A platform came out called YouTube.
I say I think it's gonna be big.
I start a wine show.
I want to promote this wine show.
How do I do that?
I'm not taking dollars from what
we were doing to sell product.
I saw a new platform called Twitter.
Then there was this
website called Summize.
What Summize built was
a way to search Twitter,
because for the first year and change
of Twitter, you couldn't search anything
that was ever tweeted.
Summize had a search engine.
I used it for 15 hours a day.
I don't know if you remember this,
when I started coming in at like 10:30
because I was up til 4:30 in the morning
because I would stay and work seven,
eight, nine hours, 10, 12 hours
searching every wine term.
Chardonnay, Pinot Noir, Bordeaux, Napa,
of anybody tweeting anything, because
nobody knew who the fuck I was.
So I read somebody saying, "I'm going to
"Napa today," on Twitter,
'cause Silicon Valley, right?
"Going to Napa today
to drink some Merlot."
I replied, "what kind
of Merlot do you like?"
They replied, "Duck Horn."
I replied, "Overpriced."
They replied.
I would do that for 15 hours a day,
and I did it for four and a half years
before anybody knew who the fuck I was.
(clapping)
VaynerMedia was started in Budding Media's
conference room because we didn't
have enough money to pay for rent.
I live my advice.
Patience.
You don't have the money?
I get it.
Go and reply to every single
person in Atlanta on Twitter.
It's free.
And if you really really
really really really
want it bad, you'll stay up to
one o'clock in the morning and do it.
And if that's too much for your body,
listen to your body, don't get sick.
But this is the game.
Either put in the work or you don't.
There's a lot of push back to hard work.
I'm not on that bandwagon.
Hard work is the only thing I know
that works when you don't have money.
You have money, trust fund,
hit the lotto, made it already?
Use it.
Facebook ads.
(laughter)
Don't have money?
You have hustle.
People are starting to try to demonize
hustle here and there
in different pockets.
Hustle's gonna be put on a pedestal
when the world collapses.
- [Male] Thank you, Gary,
for putting this on.
And thanks again for the
advice you gave us last year.
It helped quadruple our business.
- [Gary] Can you tell everybody just four
seconds of it 'cause it's so real.
Because I remember sitting in that,
we had a mix-up as a
post-game to a keynote,
and so we met an at airport hotel.
We had condensed time.
It was funny, I was
telling you and your wife
yesterday I knew you were gonna do it.
It's just in that short period of time,
that kind of financial impact excites me.
So just for the benefit of everybody to
inspire them not hearing it from me,
hearing it from somebody who did it.
- [Male] Sure, so my wife
who's sitting over there,
Kerry Shoal, we run a real estate team in
Northern Virginia,
D.C.
- I hate glasses.
- [Male] Maryland area.
We were already number one in that area.
We met with you, the time was condensed,
but you were very flexible
and made it happen
despite the mix-up which
I think was a third party,
not anybody with you.
And we got about 45 minutes.
You really dove into
what exactly we needed
to put out on social media, Facebook,
Instagram, all of that,
and it was pretty simple.
I mean you could boil it down to just
be the digital mayor of your town.
Be the--
- [Gary] Which, by the way.
I think I did it first
out of an Inman talk
in 2009 was when I came up with it,
improv on stage.
I was like just be the fucking mayor.
I'm still obsessed with somebody here
filling up the pothole on main street,
and filming it and making
the whole town love that.
- [Male] Yeah, that was
the example you gave us.
- [Gary] I want that one.
- [Male] So we went out
and did a whole bunch
of series, just going
to restaurants, bars,
neighborhoods, and
filming like a two minute
highlight reel of what that bar was about,
what that restaurant was about,
and then promoting it on a
local blog that was paid.
Running Facebook ads to that area.
And all of a sudden, people were.
It didn't work for about a month or two,
but then all of a sudden
people were like shit, I'm
seeing you everywhere.
- By the way,
the amount of people
that bail at that month
or two part, is a lot because
these industries, why I'm
attacking it, are sales driven.
And so all the other voices are like whoa,
that's bullshit, you spent a thousand,
we didn't get a sale,
go back to cold-calling.
Tried and true.
- [Male] Yeah, so all of a sudden
people were like we see you everywhere,
everywhere, everywhere.
We cut our direct mail.
We went from like 15 thousand a month
in direct mail to zero overnight,
and put it all into
Facebook and Instagram,
LinkedIn, YouTube, and
it took about two and half, three months,
and then we exploded.
Normally in December, we
would do about 20 deals
for 12 million, and we ended up around
86 deals for 52 million in one month.
(clapping)
So my question is, and thank you for that.
My question is, how do
we scale it and make it
even bigger?
- More.
- And when you're doing that, how do
you balance the need to just put out
a fuckton more but still be authentic
to your voice and true to your brand
because it's a lot of
stuff to look.
- Talk about more shit.
- 'Cause I imagine for you, like you've
probably got 15, 16, 20 people just
working on your personal brand,
like how do you make sure they're putting
out stuff that matches your
voice and what you want.
- [Gary] Because I post
everything and write all the copy.
Guys I post every single Instagram post.
And every Tweet, it's me.
I write the copy.
Like when Caleb was filming me today,
there's even things I've said where
I give him a look so he can remember
to cut out that part, otherwise they
watch and look for the good stuff.
Then it goes into a text
chain with 20 people.
I approve if I like it.
Sometimes I like the
title they put at the top,
sometimes I don't, I change it.
Then I take it.
There's a reason there's
only one post today,
we've been busy here.
(laughter)
It's authentic 'cause it's authentic.
- [Male] How do you avoid
you being the speed bump
then to--
- You can't outsource
a personal brand.
It's a personal brand.
I don't.
I'm just working harder than you.
- [Male] So how much time
a day are you putting it
just copywriting.
- Today, less.
- [Male] Editing, in a normal day.
- [Gary] When I go take a poop.
(laughter)
Like there's a reason why a post
always comes for you
guys on Instagram around
8:50 to like--
(laughter)
No, no, I'm already, it's because it's
a really good time for me.
And you know it's fun to
have my, it's honestly.
And this is about life, like honestly
it's fun to have my parents here.
I've started speaking less to my mom
in the last year and a half because
I need that five minutes
to get that one post out,
and that doesn't make
me happy, by the way,
that's just the truth to your answer.
The reason you'll see so much from me
at 8:50 to 9:00 is that's that little
window I'm in the car right before I get
into the office where I can sneak one in,
and I also know that you guys are
starting to get to your day.
Then you're gonna get something somewhere
around noon, one, I don't eat lunch,
but it's consciously hitting me like,
fuck I need to think
about getting another one
out in the next four hours.
It's random, but it's the most valuable.
Guys (laughs) everyone's like when do I
do this when I have to do my real job.
I'm like your fucking real job's
bullshit, this is the game.
- [Male] So are you actually on the
Instagram app typing it
with your thumbs, or are you
doing it--
- No my fucking tongue.
Yes, I'm posting it.
(laughter)
Me.
- [Male] I didn't know
if they gave it to you
and you did it in a
different program, or you
tee'd up a couple days worth of stuff.
- [Gary] You know what's funny, Caleb was
excited about, where the fuck are you?
You're like 6'7" with
a fucking huge beard,
I can't find you, there you are, okay.
Caleb actually did a good job.
I gave him a compliment yesterday 'cause
I like the way he vlogs me.
It's a new look, fresh eyes right?
Me and D rocker in our cadence,
me and Baben were, me and Iris were.
He's brought a really good element
'cause he was a big fan and new a lot
of stuff, and there was things that he
knew weren't answered, and he's really
helping me answer things.
He filmed me yesterday posting it
on the way here for 4Ds, and he got
me to say something that
he was interested in it.
Here's what happens, I get a bunch of
pieces of content in my text
chain with the whole team.
There's clips from the videos,
'cause that's why we vlog.
Then I look at the title,
like Do the Right Thing,
you know that shit, and
sometimes I'll change it,
sometimes it's great.
When you're around people
you can get into that.
But then I watch it.
And I'll watch it and then
I'll immediately post it,
and if I get a call from my dad while I'm
in the middle of posting
it, when I'm done,
I'll have to go back in, rewatch it,
'cause I've gotta be really
fucking fresh on it, right?
Then I'll write the copy,
and then I'll post it.
And then I'll reply.
That's why I created
team Gary V, that's them.
When you get Gary V reply, that's me.
I heart it, that's me.
So that's how we do it.
- [Male] Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
Coming up to you in the top right.
Bottom-left if somebody wants to line up.
Let me tell you why that's so important
to read your comments.
The reason I've been able to continue to
come up with shit, is
'cause I read comments.
The replies to things are the things
that allow me to build on things.
It's how I got into
parenting or self-awareness
or keeping up with the Jones', it was
just one long seed to why would I.
Why is every single person here not
doing exactly what I'm saying?
That would be something
I was interested in.
And then I would read
and read, I'm like oh.
You just keep going down these paths,
you must read every comment,
you must reply to it.
Everybody here's trying
to build a huge following.
The best way to build
a huge following is to
actually give a shit about
your small following.
- [Male] A couple years
ago you gave a talk on
how much money you should
be spending on social,
where are you at now with the monthly
ad budget of what you should
be doing no matter what?
- [Gary] As much as
you can humanly afford.
- [Male] Okay.
I like hearing it from you.
- [Gary] Let me tell you why.
Facebook and Instagram attention
is grossly underpriced.
It won't be forever.
You know, like real estate.
It goes up in value.
It's coming.
'Cause Google did it.
How many people here ran Google Adwords
in 2000 to 2003, raise your hands.
Raise 'em high, raise 'em high.
Remember that shit?
It's not the same price anymore.
To me, as much as you can,
and that means being thoughtful
about what you're saving
or spending for your life,
so you can pour more into the business.
Right?
It's gonna go away.
As much as you can.
But it's content and media.
That's where everybody's
getting a little bit caught up.
Everybody's pouring more media,
but they have made 14 new, 44 new,
72 new, your one new video, one new post
away from changing the
outcome on that CAC LTV leads.
Same media spend.
33 to 47 year old women in Detroit,
different piece of content.
Eight dollars lead, four
thousand dollars of lead.
The content is the variable.
People've committed finally to the spend
to some degree,
but the people here that aren't effective
on Facebook right now, it's
your content suck's shit.
Or your content isn't contextual
against your media spend.
But the value is clear as day,
and it will go away.
- [Male] Thank you.
- [Gary] You got it, brother.
- [Male] You keep saying
how excited you are
about this big depression
and the depression
that's coming up, and you're
half-joking, half-not but--
- [Gary] No, I'm 100
percent fucking serious.
There's no joking.
I've eaten shit for the last nine years
to put me in a position to capitalize.
Guys, nine years ago when
I started VaynerMedia,
do you know how much, you do,
client service businesses suck.
Nine years ago, I was on fire.
I just invested in Facebook and Twitter,
and nobody even knew this
social, and the digital,
I was on TechCrunch all the time,
Zucks and all these fucking fancy
fucking people were my friends.
I should have, like many of my friends who
were not as on fire as
me, I could've raised a
300 million dollar fund, took two points
for just running it.
Do you understand the math on that?
And had 20 percent of the fucking back-end
for being somebody who just took fucking
meetings and gave out cash to
invest hoping something hit.
Instead I built a
business that sucks shit.
I'm not joking at all, my guy.
I fucking put a decade in
to build the foundation
to fucking capitalize 'cause I wanna
buy the Jets and win Super Bowls.
- [Male] Alright good, so talk to me.
- [Gary] Joking.
- [Male] Real estate, the
limited barrier to entry,
a lot of bullshit artists out there,
Director of Sports, Director of Redheads,
there's all these
bullshit titles out there.
But really.
- [Gary] Are you the director of redheads?
(laughter)
- No.
You know what I'm talking about.
- [Gary] Of course I do.
- [Male] The housing
market is at a slow-down,
especially Miami, and a
lot of people are trying
to fluff it and talk a big game,
and oh it's great, but no, but yes,
but bottom line is, we all
know where the fuck we're at.
- [Gary] And it's gonna get worse.
- [Male] Exactly, thank you.
What's your advice to
prepare for that getting
worse--
- Have cash.
- [Male] And what's your advice to prepare
in that industry when there's that
stand-still--
- Buy shit.
- [Male] Well there's a period of time
where there's a stand-still
and then all the
funds are on--
- Maximize cash.
- [Male] Real estate.
People.
- [Gary] You know what's happening next.
So maximize cash right now.
And maximizing cash comes in two ways.
There's people like me who
just makes a lot of cash,
and there's people like my
parents who spend no cash.
If my parents and I teamed
up, we'd be trillionaires.
(laughter)
Everybody here could figure out how
they're going to maximize cash.
For me, for most people who aren't capable
of doing what I'm doing, which
is just generate so much,
it's probably better to be
thoughtful about your spending.
Right?
- [Male] Right, I mean look there's that
period of stand-still,
everyone's like oh no,
we're at the bottom, the bottom's coming.
- [Gary] You'll appreciate this.
This is gonna make a lot of sense to you,
I value the depression
so much that I've been
waiting for the stand-still, I've been
in the stand-still for four years.
I just know that a hundred
thousands dollars today.
See what people do, they're not smart.
They don't think it's the bottom yet,
so they're trying to pull
a couple more sheckles
out while it's good, right?
What they don't realize
is that a hundred thousand
dollars, when it's a
nightmare economic world,
is worth 750 thousand,
and they're not gonna
be able to pull out 750
in this little window.
So am I happy that I haven't
maximized all my cash?
No, I'm not thrilled.
Am I gonna be super pumped
when the shit hits the fan?
Super pumped.
Here's the best part, I'm telling
everybody it's gonna happen.
- It's not the--
- You can do it too.
It's so black and white, you know.
- [Male] Oh my god,
it's insane.
- If you're in your shit.
If you are in your shit, and it sounds
like you're in your shit in Miami,
it's not gonna get better.
It's over-built, it's over-leveraged,
tax implications, it's fucked.
- [Male] But then this time is gonna
be much slower than 2008,
there's no doubt about it.
- 100 thousand percent.
- It's happening for different
reasons.
- Brother, or maybe not.
Maybe the current
President, and the current
atmosphere and whoever else, maybe they've
decided to put a huge bandaid too.
I don't know, what I know
is shit's gonna hit hard.
- [Male] No doubt about that.
- [Gary] So my advice
is don't try to get cute
and get a little out,
maximize fucking cash.
- [Male] God bless.
- [Gary] Right?
I told Zach to his face, I'm like we gotta
hit a big fucking number in speaking
this year, I want the cash.
- [Male] Gary, once again thank
you so much for everything--
- [Gary] What, is it
cozy as fuck up there?
Are the seats that cozy you
don't wanna ask questions,
what the fuck's going on up there?
- [Male] The hungry
people come to the front.
- [Gary] Good.
I think they're just better chairs, bro,
these look like shit.
Go ahead.
- [Male] They are
digging into the asshole.
(laughter)
I have a team of 12, not everyone is
interesting, not content
in this industry.
Real estate as an industry is not always
the most interesting.
- [Gary] Who says?
- [Male] Oh, me.
- [Gary] Right, you're
one fucking dude, dick.
- I know.
(laughter)
- [Gary] You don't get to say.
- [Male] Fair enough.
- [Gary] Right?
- [Male] But you say I do.
- [Gary] No, no, you do for you.
- [Male] Right, right.
- [Gary] But not for the consumer.
- [Male] True enough, true enough.
- [Gary] I'm jumping in and making a joke
to make a very big point,
some people think it's
really boring to watch
men run into each other and play football.
I think it's the most
interesting shit in the world.
Other people decide watching six episodes
of Escaping R Kelly is
fucking fascinating.
(laughter)
I do not.
The audience gets to decide.
So I keep telling people here,
they're like I'm not interesting.
I'm like the only thing
you got is that you're
actually interesting
because you're uniquely you.
The biggest advantage everybody here has
when it comes to this
concept, is their truth.
But everybody tries to
do what's the right thing
to do and they start
to vanilla themselves.
- [Male] So go deeper
and deeper into content,
as deep as I can get.
- [Gary] Correct, about anything.
Like, "tripped today."
(laughter)
Hurt my ankle.
Post.
- [Male] Thank you so much, Gary.
- [Gary] The third
comment's gonna be like,
"I fucking hurt my ankle too today!"
We're humans guys.
We're humans.
I mean it, it's why reality TV won.
Reality TV got shit on.
Social media got shit on.
The closer to the truth, the better.
We like it, it's why we rubberneck.
That's why we try to like sit and listen
to other people's conversations,
it's what we do.
We're interested.
And so we have to talk about more.
You know?
- [Male] Thank you.
- [Gary] You got it, brother.
I gotta go catch a plane.
- [Female] Thank you.
(clapping)
- [Male] One more!
- You want it?
- Yeah, I want it.
- [Gary] Your shirt is
pretty fucking phenomenal.
- [Male] Aw thanks, dude.
- [Gary] Go ahead, Devon.
- [Male] Alright Devon Shryan from Hawaii,
hey everybody thanks for having me.
I think real estate is
moving towards the Amazon,
which means I think it takes way too
long to buy a house,
it should take 45 days.
- [Female] Appreciate it.
- Here, okay got it.
- Yeah.
- [Male] I think it take 45 days
to buy a house, sometimes two months.
I really think you should
be able to walk in,
maybe on a Monday, you
get yours keys on Friday,
you're good to go, and
I think that's where
real estate gonna end up
maybe in 10, 20 years.
I would love to be on the front--
- [Gary] Definitely Devon, real quick?
Let me tell you how, blockchain.
- Blockchain, yeah.
- Blockchain.
That's what blockchains can gonna do.
When it's me and him, and none of you
fuck faces get in the middle,
I'm gonna move in on fucking Friday,
he's gonna give me the keys on Friday.
Fuck Monday.
It's coming.
- [Male] And I wanna
be on the front of it.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Male] Thoughts?
(laughter)
- [Gary] Build apps on
blockchain and wait 17 years
for it to be at scale
since you're young as fuck.
You know, start putting out content around
these thoughts as you're
thinking them through.
I mean that's what I got for you.
How are you practically gonna be at the
forefront of right now, tomorrow
making house purchases
go from Friday to Monday?
- [Male] I don't know.
- [Gary] You can't.
There's too much infrastructure and too
much logistics in the middle in the way
the industry's structured right now.
You don't have the leverage.
The only leverage one can have,
is putting out content to create new ideas
and get people to rally behind them,
and that's what I would do.
You know?
- [Male] Yeah.
- [Gary] The tools are not in place yet.
I wanna go to Mars and eat a fruit.
Cool, how?
There's too many processes and state laws,
there's just too much shit right now.
We're gonna need a human restructure.
The last human restructure
was called the internet,
it really is in the
process of restructuring.
The next one will be blockchain.
Blockchain has the infrastructure to
play out the dream that you have.
You're gonna have to wait.
Good news is, you're young.
You'll see it.
But I think you should
start talking about it.
Podcasts, content, things like that.
Guys thank you so much.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump here at the end
because I'm working on a ridiculously
important project for me, and I have
a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all, or know anybody
that drinks wine at all, please go to
empathywines.com right now and sign up
for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack,
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year,
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.